they are calling it operation dolphin
one taking place off the coast of
Valletta this is the first ever joint
Naval exercise between Malta and Libya
this is a great exercise and a great
motivation for our staff to learn and
develop themselves the agreement signed
by Valletta and Tripoli in 2020 aimed at
Caribbean migration from Libya across
the Mediterranean Sea to Malta has seen
much success in 2019 more than 3 400
migrants arrived here by sea but
following the agreement those numbers
have drastically declined every year so
far this year only 142 people have
reached Malta from Libya the migration
problem is is not only malta's problem
it is an EU problem and but we are a
small island in the center of the
Mediterranean and we we are affected
more than other countries according to
officials here these drills are part of
a training program to help Libya develop
their Maritime capabilities Clinton
O'Neill is the commander of the Maltese
Armed Forces so our cooperation with
them is is a capacity building so so
um we we are there to train them and in
in techniques and in Maritime Affairs
and in Maritime operational law and then
they practice that in their own in their
own country the drills include medical
evacuations vessel inspections and
search and rescue operations training
these Waters the central Mediterranean
Sea has been described by the UN as the
most dangerous Maritime Crossing in the
world with more than twenty thousand
recorded deaths since 2014.
so far this year more than 500 people
have died and nearly 850 have gone
missing in these Waters trying to reach
Europe but more than 8 800 have been
intercepted at Sea and returned to Libya
Pepe works for an Italian NGO that
rescues migrants in the Mediterranean he
says the pushbacks to Libya are illegal
why Libya is not a safe country and
Libya cannot be a safe part of this
embarkation many say these drills are
part of an EU policy to externalize its
borders and keep migrants out others say
Libyan authorities commit widespread
abuse against migrants but these
officers here say they are just trying
to do their jobs malc trainer Al Jazeera
off the coast of Malta